if you want the posh english voice kylie
no
you have a trick is this is this like
the boneless chicken
did you develop this trick yourself if i
yes i did i don't know why
but um to sound very british but more
specifically like a couple of pims by 10
30 a.m kind of british
oh yeah you just don't let your lips
touch
a little bit more difficult
honestly i guarantee a trap you're going
to violence it's fabulous
don't try it graeme okay
i've had several pins
now use time approaches uh kylie this
new album
which i have actual copy here
it's finally out today and you know i
was lucky enough to hear something
earlier and you know how much i love it
so um the reviews i mean you must be
thrilled everyone
this is i'm pretty chuffed yeah i'm just
i'm pleased that it's
worked yeah it's such a i guess it's
like making a film it's such a journey
to
even just launch into her again like the
30th year of my career of music to go
can i do this uh yeah
i think i can do it i'm really happy
with the results because you talked
about how personal this album is a lot
of the tracks are i mean
really love like this some love letters
to your fans
songs about your relationship with music
and things but i read an interview where
you were saying that
when you started writing the songs they
were just too personal they didn't work
they were rubbish and i'm really glad
they were rubbish because i just
got through break up yawn and
and so i kind of just got all this stuff
out of my system and then
you know i'm searching for the song
searching for what's what is the dna of
this album what's it going to be
and kind of six months in got to
nashville and it all made sense and by
that time
i'd reclaimed myself i felt great i
felt absolutely so happy to be working
and kind of
you know um on my own path again
so it turned it transpired that the the
good songs came later which i'm really
happy about
and the title is such a great title for
an album
golden it's you know because it's a
picture you're so
beautiful in that picture thank you
highly golden gold available now
and this is a sweet thing kind of going
full circle
uh that in uh australia the album's
going to be
promoted by your original label from 30
years ago
yes yeah yeah so i signed with a company
called
mushroom records in 87.
this is a long time ago
[Laughter]
this is kind of cool because see this
album
it's older than him
look at that hat we you can't look at
that without
what it is yeah it's not really a hat is
it it's more of a
brim it's a brim yeah yeah so that was
the thing
i i probably not yeah but that's your
hair though right that is my hair
yeah great for calling taxis
in australia
yeah did god i can't believe it so i
signed with um
this company yeah in 87 so it's over 30
years ago and
and i'm still releasing records with
them in australia
[Music]